allez on y va c'est parti une
déambulation au départ du quartier des
épis noirs pour l'état ferait les
militants de la liste écologique et
solidaire tout à faire pour plaisir dit
taf sont allés à la rencontre des
habitants armés de branches de bambou
pour présenter leurs tracts nous on est
sur le terrain à chaque fois on
rencontre fait plaisir oies et on voit
que lee enfin eux nous disent qu'il y à
des dysfonctionnements on écoute ce
qu'ils nous disent et et non seulement
on écoute mais on s'est aussi engagé à
travailler là dessus et à faire des
propositions des propositions également
réfléchi lors d'ateliers avec les
plaisirs watts depuis fin novembre
orienté sur les solidarités en recréant
du lien entre les quartiers aisés entre
les générations et sur l'écologie
plaisir malheureusement est voué aux
voitures
ok une autre façon de voir une autre
façon de recréer sur le terrain des
choses des éléments qui permettent de
satisfaire les plaisirs wa candidate
sans étiquette la liste citoyenne est
tout de même soutenu par europe ecologie
les verts et le parti socialiste et
revendique ses valeurs écologistes et de
gauche
je constate tous les jours le
l'augmentation des constructions
la non prise en charge de certaines
populations et je trouve ça vraiment
dommage donc je fais entièrement
confiance à cette liste et on saisit des
pour pouvoir essayer d'améliorer les
choses tout à faire pour plaisir a
poursuivi sa déambulation jusqu'à la
gare plaisir des clés trois autres
listes sont déclarés pour les élections
municipales dans la commune à bientôt